To get started,
we should first create a scripts task.
However, since we want to do slightly
different things in development and
production mode.
We add another task called scripts-dist,
which will be used when we want to
distribute our fights for production.
In the first step,
both of these tasks will look the same.
We gulp source the files we need,
in this case, our JavaScript files.
Then pipe them to the correct
destination, in our case,
the dist/js folder.
Now install the gulp-concat plug-in via
npm, and require in the gulp file, then
add a new pipe to both tasks with concat
all JS before the destination pipe.
This plugin takes the files
in the stream, and
combines them into a single file named
whatever you provide as the argument.
Try running one of those
task in your terminal,
to make sure the concatenated all.js
ends up in the correct folder.
All good.
Then we're missing only one last thing.
We need to change the references to the
individual js files in our index HTML to
point to the single js file,
at js/all.js.
And now your page should run fine again.